what's going on guys
the latest offering from the Coen
brothers is hitting theaters so we at
screen junkies are taking it upon
ourselves to definitively come up with
the number one Coen Brothers film of all
time and we have an esteemed panel to
help us with this monumental task
let's see who's with us today first oh
she's a great friend of the show you
know from profiles and screen junkies
Plus Alicia Malone
also repping the dude you know him from
profiles with Malone and mance as well
and access Hollyweird Hollyweird got
miss and the movie fights champion our
old friend and Merle you guys Coen
Brothers first they are some of the most
esteemed oat ORS in Hollywood all of the
movies as different as they can be they
are all uniquely Coen Brothers films so
we've got the good ones we've got the
bad ones we've got the ugly ones and
we've ranked them according to their
IMDB rankings their top 16 films our
first matchup let's start off with the
number one seed against the number 16
seed Fargo will it be taken down by the
number 16 lady killers Alicia you're the
lady killer let's go easy easy choice
Fargo this lady has just killed lady
killers killing lady killers Fargo all
the way dan are you yeah Tom Hanks is
doing something really wacky in that
movie and JK Simmons is actually really
funny in that none of it and the Battle
of the funny accents I gotta say you
betcha - Fargo oh yeah horse Fargo moves
on all right next up Barton Fink Oh
versus the man who wasn't there
Oh both great films I like the
experimental nests of a man who wasn't
there only black and white very
melancholic with Billy Bob Thornton but
I have to go with Barton Fink it's like
The Shining done by the Cohens
shows what he'll writers go through to
change you create their process I think
that the man who wasn't there is a very
kind of under credited little gem of a
movie I think people forget about it and
the Coen brothers filmography I think
that Billy Bob Thornton has a fantastic
performance in that movie I will cast my
vote for the man who wasn't there he are
all locked up at one one and we're
coming to scott man's to decide well
for me the man who wasn't there was the
movie that wasn't there I admired the
performances the black and white the
cinematography but Bart and think
there's so much ambiguity to that film
so many haunting scenes it's unnerving
it's funny shot to Torres great John
Goodman is great it's a terrific movie
and that gets my vote Fink thinks the
man who wasn't there oh brother where
art thou at number five versus hudsucker
proxy who's a good guy and let's start
with Scott man I'm gonna go with the
hudsucker proxy I remember liking when I
first came out yeah I still love it now
you don't need to really like the Coen
brothers to enjoy the movie it stands on
its own merits that's why I'm going with
hudsucker boom one for hudsucker Alicia
Malone I have to go with AI brother were
out there it's one of my favorite Coen
Brothers movies of all time because it
has you know a bit of Homer in there a
bit of Sullivan's Travels a bit of
magical realism George Clooney plays a
great idiot so much to love so much
great music so that's why I have to
choose that one okay we are locked up at
one one coming to Dan Merle I mean I
agree with Scott that the hudsucker
proxy is their most commercially
accessible movie mm-hmm but Syria I feel
like in doing that they lost a little
bit of that Coen Brothers magic and oh
brother Oh out that was so unique and it
makes me laugh so hard it revolutionized
the way that post-production is handled
in film the way that they did the color
grading on that movie which is now
something that almost every means he
does Wow that movie is what started that
whole revolution I got to go with over
okay number four against number 13
Miller's Crossing at number four versus
a serious man this is a tougher
competition this than the seating would
have you believe because a serious man
this is the most love it or hate it of
all of their movies and for me a serious
man worked and I got to go with that one
oh I'm gonna go with Miller's Crossing
but it's so close because I'm a serious
man
gotcha let's go to Scott man that is
really a tough call a serious man the
ambiguity of that movie stay with me
long after I left the theater the more
you see it the way you get out of it it
stands up it holds Oh
time with PETA viewings I'm going with
resonates with a Jew as well it
certainly does my son a serious man
number 13 knocking off a little in it
yeah Wow
we're gonna hear about that one no
country for old men against burn after
reading I do too have a lot to love with
Burn After Reading you don't great Coen
Brothers idiots but I have to go with no
country for old men it is bleak it's a
it's a Great Western one of the best
villains we've seen on screen a long
time Cole yeah oh man okay I'm going No
Country for Old Men it won the Oscar for
Best Picture and Best Director and I
love burning after reading Brad Pitt
yeah but No Country for Old Men is a
daring film there's no score it is very
very intense No Country for Old Men the
number three seed moving on the number
six film versus the number 11 film ooh
this one okay I am very conflicted here
number six
True Grit against number 11 Raising
Arizona Dan we're starting with you if
we're crowning the best Coen Brothers
movie true grit is a really good movie
but raising Arizona is such a
distinctive Coen Brothers movie I've got
to go with raising Arizona boom one for
raising Arizona
this one isn't so hard for me I've got
to go with raising Arizona for the
reasons that Dan said True Grit is a
well-made film but it doesn't feel very
Coen Brothers esque I think it's
actually their highest grossing film but
gracing Arizona with the crazy lovable
Nicolas Cage oh yeah yeah that was one
of my ends to the Cohens I've been
absolutely same here number seven Blood
Simple against number 10 inside Lewis
Davis oh and let's start with Scott
mance inside Llewyn Davis not only wins
this round it is my personal favorite
Coen Brothers movie of all time the
music is great and the cinematography is
fantastic not by Roger Deakins because
he was off doing something else but why
Oscar Isaac did not get nominated for an
Academy Award for that film is beyond me
he was fantastic in it thank you Scott
mance that is one for inside Llewyn
Davis and we're going to Dan Merle for
me and silo and Davis was one of those
that I admire didn't quite hit a chord
with Jerry as much as some of their
other words
and when I think about blood simple
which a lot of people haven't seen that
you should see it there is a sequence in
that movie that is just Hitchcockian the
tension that they are able to build and
that has stuck with me since I saw the
movie and that was a long time ago it's
true and so I think I go blood simple on
this one we are locked up at one one
yeah Alicia fresh it comes down to you
yeah I'm feeling the pressure because
blood simple such an impressive debut
for the Cohens and it really sets up
everything that you see in later Coen
Brothers movie inside Llewyn Davis as
one of the best films for the last few
years such a great ode to those starving
artists and people that didn't quite
make it I'm gonna have to go with inside
Llewyn Davis boom whoo okay the number
two film The Big Lebowski tenth boy
versus intolerable cruelty well are you
really really cruel to this movie yeah
all I want to say about this is that rug
really tied the room together much like
Donnie in Tobruk rules he's out of its
element here right you're only talking
enough to go that's gonna have to go the
bracket is set for the next round let's
go back our number1 seed Fargo against
our number 8 seed barton fink
oh ho we're gonna start with dan moreau
on this one for me Fargo was one of the
first independent films I ever saw it
was when independent film was starting
to make its way and penetrate into the
heartland of America it wasn't just for
the coasts anymore I'd never seen
anything like it before and that really
made an impression on me I have to go
far go Scott map because it go with
Fargo based on a true story and it's
just like is Fargo actually based on a
true story yes yeah and not Church no
based on Teresa was a taster yeah Wow
just witnessed it folks a fun fact that
Scott mance did not I got wrong you are
right 99.9 percent of the time I was
with this one that was like Halley's
Comet right okay Fargo the first member
of our Final Four now let's see our
second round of eight matchup oh brother
where art thou the number five seed
against the number 13 seed a serious man
Alicia God
my brother out versus serious man ah I'm
going to stick with our brother we're
out there I have such a love for that
film great road movie as well as a fairy
tale so I'll go with that one oh brother
thank you sister
Scott man that's tough choice I just you
know praise the hell out of serious man
and I mean I like oh brother brought
there are a lot mostly because of the
music and the cinematography like you
pointed out but I'm going with the
serious man just because it was one that
stayed with me long after I left the
theater
we are tied up Dan Merle has a serious
decision I have very bad you know
brother were out there came out nobody
got it it was mixed it was mixed people
said it was terrible George Clooney won
a Golden Globe people like what for that
well that was terrible and then over
time people began to find it as great as
the serious man is I honestly believe
that oh brother where art thou is one of
the best comedies made in the 21st
century so I have to go with that Dan I
didn't know you were such an OBE ruther
head I love that movie I really do
oh brother where art thou moves into the
final four all right next round of eight
match up we've got two more who a
barnburner No Country for Old Men versus
Raising Arizona well Dan Merle this is
almost impossible to do because it's
it's it's like 40 it's if if I have to
choose I would say the the deeper film
and the one that left more of an
impression on me and the one that I
thought about more after it was over
would have to be breaking our country
would have to be No Country for Old Men
Alicia Malone I have to go with No
Country for Old Men as well not an easy
choice for kids like you said they to
flip sides of the Coens the tragedy
versus the comedy but it really did
leave an impression on me like you said
Dan it's so dark and disturbing and so
beautifully made at the same time so I'm
going with no country Scott man so gosh
you're for Old Manse
yeah Country for Old Manse okay No
Country for Old Men is in the Final Four
one more round of eight matchup inside
Llewyn Davis versus The Big Lebowski Oh
Scott man let's go what I've gone with
Lo and Davis baby
LuAnn Davis I know that's sacrilege but
I know it's a bummer dude you sir are
not welcome at Lebowski fast
my question for you Lebowski again is I
saw it when I was too young I think it
was 15 years old when I saw it the first
time when it came out I didn't get it I
didn't I didn't get anything about it
yeah I revisited it a few years later
when I was a little bit older and it's
one of the few movies I see something
new every time I watch we're all tied up
this is a matchup for the ages
Alicia Malone comes down to you I'm
gonna go with Big Lebowski
there you go but beautifully made films
both have so much to love but as for a
film that I just will watch time and
time and time and time and time and time
again it's The Big Lebowski Big Lebowski
rolls into the Final Four
the first matchup of the final four
Fargo versus oh brother where art thou
oh gosh why are you making me choose
between my favorite because that's what
we signed up for here today god damn it
uh it's not an easy choice but I will go
with Fargo just in terms of it being the
classic Coen Brothers movie I'm gonna go
with Fargo as well I think I like oh
brother worth out not as much as these
two but I still like it just not as much
as them but I love Fargo so boom Dan
yeah I mean again I love o brother where
art thou but just that last scene in
Fargo alone with with with Frances
McDorman in the car when she's talking
trying to talk to Peter Stormare and
just like all for a little bit of money
there's more to life than a little money
you know don't you know that
Fargo moving on to the finals this one I
mean let's just call it a day
yes this is too tough No Country for Old
Men versus The Big Lebowski
oh we're gonna start with Dan Moreau oh
of course
great ah Big Lebowski has so much going
for it and even like even the little
things philip Seymour Hoffman's from my
favorite people in that movie and he has
like two lines I just like to watch him
standing his on the sidelines his laughs
and uh Tara Reed at the height of her
high different powers but I think I got
to go with no country Javier Bardem in
that movie and we haven't really talked
about it the best movie villain yeah
since Darth Vader Hannibal Lecter maybe
Darth Vader just call it friend o14 no
country now I go to one of the two
people who are wearing Big Lebowski
t-shirts
Alicia Malone I'm gonna cause some
trouble yeah um and probably get some
YouTube paid for this but I'm going to
go with Big Lebowski just in terms of a
film that made such a huge impression on
me when I was younger I love no country
as well so it's tough choice but I'm
just going to go Big Lebowski which
means you're all tied up guys go Samar
thanks a lot you guys how to go about
sorry guys I gotta go
no you can't no we are going to hold you
here I get more old men ah we just broke
the internet Big Lebowski eliminated No
Country for Old Men moves on to the
finals gentlemen lady here is your final
matchup Fargo versus No Country for Old
Men the number one seed against the
number three seed and we're going to
start with Alicia Malone oh really
really tough choice um but I have to
stick with Fargo
all right we're going right down the
line Scott mance I love Fargo I love
Fargo yeah I don't know what I came out
in 96 so I was like my god this movie is
amazing like I felt like at that time it
was the Coen brothers best Finity until
I saw no country for old men no country
for old men takes it we're all locked up
at one one
Merl you are not in an Envy I'm not I'm
in your worst position I don't know why
I put myself in this position if I'm
looking at these two choices and if I'm
going to say this is the best Coen
Brothers movie the one that I think I
would look at and say this best
represents the Coen Brothers
I have to go with Fargo because the one
thing we haven't talked about is the
comedy in that film you see something
down there chief
no I just think I'm gonna burn
I got to go Fargo yes we did it Fargo
the greatest Coen Brothers film of all
time
and that's it what do you think of our
decision Wow
what do you guys think how was that to
go through although it's really tough it
was like being put into a chipper but
tough what did you think of our choices
let us know in the comments section
below
what's your top Coen Brothers movie and
why best answer we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
our fantastic guests always great to
have all you guys Alicia Malone Scott
manse Dan Murrow I'll see you around the
office I they sleep in here thank you
for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up
on Twitter bye bye so today what have
any names that are not on yeah I had to
do something from Star Wars so that the
guy that yelled traitor traitor here
traitor traitor nick has the rock as
Best Actor Best Supporting Actor Best
Actress and Best Supporting Actress
after Furious 7 he plucks out a goddamn
cat